foreign
[Music]
Navi and the oceanic metcaina Clans but
there are quite a few more tribes and
races of these blue aliens in Pandora so
here we will showcase all 17 Navi tribes
races avatars and hybrids now let's get
to it
number one the omatikaya this is the
most well-known type of Navi and they
are a forest race they have a deep
connection to the jungle and the
wildlife in The Woodlands of Pandora
they have a slim body very long hands a
thin tail and formally reside in a home
tree and later hiding in the Hallelujah
floating mountains they have a dark blue
complexion and are experts in writing
Banshees
number two the met kaina this is a very
different race of Navi and is an oceanic
Clan and have very different set of
physiological traits like finn-like
lower arms and legs by extension of the
cartilage a pedal-like tail bigger and
wider placed eyes a turquoise skin color
and wave-like stripes and appear to be
bulkier in body size they also bond with
marine animals like the ilu the skim
wing and the tolkens
this is a relatively lesser-known Navi
Clan and are theorized to be the first
Navi on the planet Moon of Pandora they
are probably the ancestors or the
precursors of the forest navis since
they reside in a home tree in the valley
of Origins there are theories that
suggest that navis are actually from
elsewhere or were genetically engineered
which we will discuss in another video
and these ni auwe were the first of them
Number Four The Tao Kami this is a
tranquil Forest Navi tribe that lives in
a settlement of greenhome deep in the
pandoran jungle this Clan has always
kept a close check on awas ecology in
order to keep it in balance and it is
famed for its never-ending search for
knowledge and law keeping also known as
the sky seers the value knowledge record
keeping chemistry and research similar
to humans
number five the tipani this was one of
the first tribes of Pandora to make
contact with humans they are spiritual
but also crafty and extremely lethal in
battle they live in a dozen villagers
where armor and Mars and are well known
for their ability to wage war and fight
the tipani travel light-footed and
unseen because of their lofty size sheer
strength acute hearing and Keen eyesight
number six the olangi this is a nomadic
Navi community that lives by moving
around following Wildlife throughout its
periodic migration patterns they dwell
in the shadow of the huge trees that
cover the plains in weaker Cottages
constructed by long grasses or wood the
Clans specialize in Cavalry and relies
on die horses during battle fighting to
prevent the advance of RDA am suits and
infantry forces during the battle in the
first movie number 7 the tehrangi also
known as the ikran people of the Eastern
Sea they are a coastal Navi tribe noted
for their Banshee riding prowess
comparable to their Northern sister Clan
dekuken since they live in the coastal
areas their adaptations to Oceanic life
isn't as developed as the metcaina but
also more evolved than the forest races
and they might be an intermediary
between the two
number eight anurai another Forest tribe
the anurai are great crafters and
Artisans they labor meticulously on
their crafts gaining inspiration from
the elements around them the anurai
adore the thanator Pandora's fiercest
and land predator and it is their totem
animal most members of the anurag clan
have been slaughtered unfortunately in
recent years
number 9 the Leona also a first tribe
but other most affected by human
factories and industrialization since
they reside in now near arid and
polluted areas near those factories they
are different from many other tribes as
they are very peaceful and they did not
join in the war in the first movie
number 10 the hulanta these are the
Wetland tribes and reside in swampy
forests and marshes they are experts in
pottery and weaving often using
whirlpools in their design as they
consider water to be the most sacred
element unfortunately an RDA bombing run
killed a lot of them and they had to
find Refuge elsewhere
number 11 the huyutikaya might be
another Navi race with a couple of
distinct evolved physiological traits
with a slightly bigger tail and a
bulkier body they are known for their
adoration and variance of the
viperwolves and they frequently decorate
with viperwolf motives they also apply
white wall paints on their faces hands
feet and other places of their body to
demonstrate their fearlessness in the
face of death
number 12 the Cocoon these are another
clan of Navi little is known about their
existence however they are thought to be
better at Banshee riding than any other
Clan they are recognized for their quick
reflexes called demeanor and a brave
heart which are essential to tame a
Banshee they dress in bright colors to
show their gratitude and Trust in the
creatures that maintain their way of
life
number 13 the monk one these are another
type of navies that are very Elusive and
Littlest known about them the only thing
we know of them is that they are
welcoming to Outsiders and outcasts
which might tell us that they are a
tribe made up of outcasts and Navi
Renegades from other tribes
number 14 the ray tanu they make their
home in the desert Highlands because the
biodiversity in their environment is low
they have evolved to more primitive
Agriculture and grazing rather than
hunting because of their arid lands and
a capacity of the navi to evolve to
their surroundings very quickly they
might be more resilient have a brownish
skin color and have a lower metabolism
due to the lack of water
number 15 the Tomato this clan of Navi
is a clan that is known for their love
and respect for Banshees they are also
very close to the forest Clans and
Physiology and might be a close relative
to the kikugan clan since they often
decorate their streamers with
iconography of the Banshees
and 16 and 17 together the avatars and
hybrids these are a genetically
engineered human Navi hybrids designed
to serve as a remotely controlled vessel
for a human mind they have five fingers
instead of four the avatars tend to have
a more pronounced nose while the navi
have a flat cat-like snout they also
have small eyes hybrid offsprings of
avatars and Navi like the children of
Jake Sully and natiri exhibit the same
characteristics as their hybrid parent
while also showing a lot of the natural
Navi traits as well
so with that we come to the end of the
17 types of races tribes and hybrids of
Navi on Pandora so I hope you have
enjoyed watching this video do hit the
like button for support and subscribe
but most of all smash that Bell icon for
regular updates on new videos right here
on this channel till the next one take
care fam